♪ ♪ ♪
- Michel Charette la dernière
fois qu'on s'est rencontrés,
c'était pour la finale
de "District 31".
- Ouais.
- Est-ce qu'il y a une vie
après "District 31"?MICHEL CHARn
- Ah, tellement! Bien oui!
(rire)
Une vie plus libre, une vie
remplie de projets, c'est super.
Écoute, je suis aussi occupé,
mais ma tête est moins occupée,
je saiss pas si tu comprends
ce que je veux dire.
Parce que la tête, elle est
remplie avec "District 31", la
quantité de texte à apprendre,
bon, tout ça. Puis, quand
on tournait aussi, il fallait
être performant tout le temps
parce qu'on n'avait pas grand
prise pour chaque scène
et tout ça. Mais oui,
je suis occupé, mais j'ai du fun
à faire mes affaires, à faire
mes projets, à voir mes amis,
à travailler sur mes affaires.
De plus en plus, ça,
c'est formidable.
- Les projets, on n'aura pas
assez de cinq minutes ensemble
parce que vous avez tellement
de projets. Tout d'abord, il y a
la pièce "À l'Institut",
coécrite avec votre grand ami
François Chénier. Vous parlez
là-dedans de bipolarité.
Pourquoi avoir choisi
ce thème-là?
- Moi, j'ai toujours tripé sur
ilililm "Vol au-dessus d'un nid
de coucou", de Milos Forman.
Et j'ai fait : "J'aimerais ça
faire un "Vol au-dessus d'un nid
de coucou", mais comique, drôle,
avec des situations trippantes,
où les gens se reconnaîtront pas
nécessairement, mais vont
trouver leur compte. On va tous
connaître quelqu'un qui souffre
de telle, telle, telle maladie.
Notre but premier, c'était pas
de rire de ces gens-là.
Au contraire, c'est
de les met v v v valeur.
Mais, c'est sûr qu'on s'est
informés auprès de certaines
personnes et des professionnels
de la santé, évidemment, pour
être exact suaiaiaiains thèmes.
- Vous êtes des êtres
merveilleux, inspirants, forts!
- J'ai eu une petite émotion
lors de la répétition
de "À l'Institut" parce que
vous étiez à côté de François
Chénier, votre grand ami,
Henri Chassé aussi,
votre mentor. C'était vraiment,
là, Michel Charette,
le gars de gang.
- Bien oui, je pense que
ça me définit bien. Je suis
un gars de gang.
- Oui!
- Henri, ça a été... C'est le
gars que j'ai connu èèèèège.
C'est le gars qui m'a mis
au monde. C'est le gars qui a
changé ma vie. C'est mon mentor.
Il m'a donné confiance en moi.
Il m'a dit : "Oui, tu peux
faire ce mààààà." Donc,
il m'a coaché pour rentrer au
conservatoire. Après ça, il m'a
coaché pour mes auditions...
pour les auditions du Quat'Sous.
C'est lui qui m'a amené voir
"Le vrai monde?", la création,
qui m'est rentrée dedans.
J'ai fait : "Un jour, je veux
jouer cette pièce-là."
30 ans plus tard, avec le temps
qu'on a, puis tout ça,
l'expérience, j'ai fait :
"Hé, Henri, on le fait-tu?"
Il a fait : "OK." Je lui dis :
"Tu veux que je jo"""""
Il dit : "Je veux pas que
tu joues, je veux que tu fasses
la mise en scène comme
à l'époque." Alors, c'est comme
boucler la boucle un petit peu.
Et avec "Lonononononde?", on va
faire de la tournée à l'hiver
2023 à travers le Québec,
et après ça, on s'en va jouer
à Paris, juillet 2023.
- Oua,a,a,a,a,a, vous revenez
de Paris, là. Vous étiez là
la semaine passée.
- Oui, je suis allé là quatre
jours. On est allés rencontrer
les gens du Théâtre du Soleil,nu
la captation de cette pièce-là.
Je l'ai contactée, j'ai dit :
"Je veux aller jouer ce show-là
à Paris." Michel Tremblay doit
rayonner partout dans le monde
comme il le fait déjà. Il a pas
besoin de moi pour rayonner
partout dans le monde.
Et Ariane Mnouchkine est une fan
de Michel. Elle vient de monter
justement "Les Belles-Soeurs",
et on a soupé là. On a vu
leur spectacle qui il est là.
Ça a été... C'est un rêve
de ti-cul. Moi, je me souviens
encore de son film sur Molière,
qui a changé ma vie. J'a
"C'est un grand film."
Et tous les shows qu'elle a
montés, c'est madame Théâtre
à travers le monde. Alors, tout
ce qu'il reste à faire, c'es
le montage financier. Alors,
s'il y a des gens qui sont
intéressés à investir dans
notre magnifique projet,
on serait bien heureux. Maisc'c.
- Autre projet pour vous, vous
allez faire de la radio cet été
avec Jessica Barker. Ça ne vous
tentait pas de prendre une pauss
pas, une plage, piscine, soleil.
- Oui, oui, je le sais, mais je
suis un cas d'action. Je suis un
gars de gange e e e e e e disais
tantôt, j'aime ça être entouré.
Et je travaille souvent avec
mes amis ou des gens que je
trouve... J'ai beaucoup de
respect pour les gens qui ont du
talent et les gens compétents.
Pour moi, ça, je trouve ça
bien impressionnant.
Écoutez, on peut
du support à tout le monde
tant qu'on veut, là, mais
quand les gens veulent pas
l'utiliser, là...
- Le Michel Charette qui est
devant moilolololololololoin
du Michel Charette d'il y a
"30 Vies", gracieuseté de vos
amis Patrice Godin, Sébastien
Delorme, qui vous ont aidé
dans votre remise en f
Moi, la question qui
m'intéresse, c'est : quel a été
le moment, le déclic décisif?
Ça a été un mardi soir,
un jeudi matin?
- Euh, moment décisif,
c'est que mon fils, qui joue
dans la rue en avant de chez
nous, qui a 4 ans à l'épo
puis j'en ai 48, je pense,
quelque chose comme ça, puis
je le vois courir dans la rue
jouer au hockey. Je fais :
"OK, dans 2-3 ans, je vais-tu
être capable d'aller jouer avec
lui dans la rue, dans la rue au
hockey, de faire du vé
montagne avec lui, de le suivre?
J'ai fait : "Non, je ne serai
pas capable. Je serai pas
capable." Alors, ça a été ce
déclic-là. J'avais un genre
quatre mois devant moi. J'ai dit
à ma blonde, j'ai dit : "Ouais,
là... Bon, elle dit : "Là, là,
ça fait 15 ans que tu m'enparlee
ou ne m'en parle plus.
Je suis écoeurée." J'ai dit :
"Parfait." J'ai dit : "Il y amoe
dit : "Regarde, je m'occupe de
tout. Je m'occupe des enfants,
je m'occupe de la maisonnée.
Ce temps-là t'appartient. Mais
prends-le et fais-en quelquecho:
"Parfait." Et là, je suis parti
avec ça. Je me suis entouré.
Gros soutien psychologique,
professionnels de la santé au
niveau de la psychologie, j'ai
pas le choix. Tu peux pas faire
ça tout seul, c'est impossible.
Entraîneur, physiothérapeute,
nutritionniste, j'ai tout mis..,
et tranquillement, je l'ai fait.
J'ai plafonné. Combien de fois
je suis allé dans le bureau
de ma psychologue et j'ai juste
braillé, faire : "J'y arriverai
pas. Je ne serai pas capable.
C'est trop gros. C'est ci, c'est
ça." Elle fait : "OK, mais
reprmimimimimimimimimimin que tu
veux faire... que tu fais et tu
vas retomber à la même place."
Elle dit : "Abandonne pas."
Et cette fois-là,
j'ai jamais abandonné.
♪ Envoye, rentre, rentre ♪
♪ Rapporte-moi-z'en ♪
♪ Une grosse pizza
puis du lait au chocolat
♪ Envoye donc ♪
- Alors, comme si ce n'était pas
assez, parlons de votre dernier
projet, celui de 2024 :
votre premier spectacle en sol
- Oui!
- Ça avance, ça?
À quoi ça va ressembler?
- Très, très bien. Écoute,
c'est un one-man-show. Ça va
être une histoire. Il faut juste
faire une différence. C'est un
one-man-show. Je deviens pas
humoriste, c'est pas ça du tout.
C'est un one-man-show, comme
Guylaine Tremblay l'a fait,
comme Anne-Élizabeth Bossé
l'a fait, comme Emmanuel
Bilodeau le fait.
Oui, ça va être principalement
de l'humour. C'est
faire dans la vie puis tout ça,
mais si j'ai des moments
d'émotion, si j'ai des moments
plus de sensibilité, je vaislel,
je vais les interpréter.
Je vais avoir du fun à le faire.
- J'ai hâte de voir ça,
Michel Charette. Merci beaucoupt